Happy Thanksgiving, everyone!
But, we're here in Korea and it's time to start Chuseok.
Now, Chuseok is often billed as the Korean Thanksgiving.
It is the autumn harvest festival...
...and it always takes place on the 15th day of the 8th month of the lunar calendar.
Now it has its old history, surrounding a monthlong basket weaving competition.
But today, it's not really celebrated that way.
It's celebrated as, well, a great time for families to get together.
So, this is what happens.
You go to your ancestral hometown...
...or the hometown of the oldest living family member, and everyone goes there.
Now, it's typically celebrated over three days.
However, the actual holiday can be looked at as a five-day festival and it's a lot of fun.
During this time, families get together...
...and they go to their ancestral burial grounds and pray for their ancestors.
And they treat them with the utmost respect.
In addition, families also get together and exchange gifts.
I'm talking about a pretty interesting gift.
Because it's a harvest festival, there are a lot of special fruit packages...
...that are available this time of year.
And on a daily basis, you may go to your grocer and get a few apples for maybe 5,000 won.
During Chuseok, the apples are a little bit more special.
They're huge!
They're specially wrapped and cared for.
And they're really grown specifically for the Chuseok gift exchange.
As such, their prices are maybe 35, 45, 50,000 won for a box set.
You may be asking yourself,...
..."Can you taste the difference of 45,000 won in these two different types of fruits?"
Yes, you can.
The fruit that is grown and exchanged during Chuseok, it's amazing.
The taste, the flavor is awesome!